i'm pat
i'm from switzerland and i also study in
switzerland
and i'm a psychologist meanwhile i'm
working at novartis
my main customers and users are the
scientists
and i'm helping them to make their drug
discovery process more efficient
one of my favorite moments here was
the situation where we were given some
rules and then we had to
build something with simple materials
and
my group my team which i was
collaborating with we were so stuck to
the rules
we just couldn't break the rules i mean
it's not about breaking rules but it's a
bit
about redefining the rules and thinking
out of the box
so we couldn't do that so we failed and
then in the second round
actually we had the big aha moment and
just break
all kind of mental models we have
schemas we have heuristics human people
have
so we completely flipped everything we
did from the beginning and guess what we
won
you